MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
So if there is a
time dilation effect
due to gravitational
fields, then there's
also a redshift which is
of gravitational fields.
So a consequence
of time dilation
is a change in the
light frequency.
And I asked you to estimate
the magnitude of this effect.
And the example you want to
use is the one shown here.
So you have a tower just--
not randomly, but 22
and 1/2 meters tall.
And a light beam is sent down.
Basically, the tower is
built on this planet,
and there's gravity
that's acting.
So this is basically an
accelerating reference frame.
The length of the tower
is, again, 22 meters.
And I would like you
to just get a feeling.
How big can this effect be,
the effect of redshift here?
So please, try to work this out.
The way to think about
this is first to say, OK,
now the light--
the delta t equals
the light to travel--
is l divided by c.
The speed of light is c.
The length is l.
The change in velocity
is g, acceleration,
times l divided by c.
So the Doppler shift then is the
frequency, the new frequency,
divided by the
initial frequency.
And that can be approximated
by 1 plus delta v over c.
So we find that it's 1 plus
g times l over c square.
Now the speed of
light is pretty fast,
3 times 10 to the
9 meter per second.
And this distance is
only 22 and 1/2 meters.
So we find that this is a
tiny, tiny, tiny effect.
But nevertheless,
experimentalists at Harvard
tested this effect.
So Pound, Rebka, and Snider
in the 1950s and '60s
were able to show
this very tiny effect.
You want to know
more about this,
you can, for example, look up a
small description in Wikipedia
here.
But there's quite
some literature
on those experimental
tests [INAUDIBLE]